if everyone you ever loved suddenly
started dying and turning into
flesh-eating monsters what would you do
you're trapped on a spaceship and no one
is coming to save you i'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the necromorphs in
dead space these resource colonist
wannabes have no idea they are all about
to die these guys are deep space mining
this giant rock when they come across
something sinister as hell this massive
structure known throughout their galaxy
as the marker an alien artifact of
unknown origin worshiped by a cult-like
group back on earth known as
unitologists these scientists then let
the base know that they found a second
marker artifact just like the one back
on earth and they let their space
station take it back for testing little
do they realize that bringing this
marker back with them will be the end
for everyone on this planet this is
insane we've just found the second
marker ever in existence like this is a
huge deal now we know a little bit about
it based on the religious text but the
fact that we found this on a dead planet
with markings everywhere like someone
has been here before means that i'd
think twice before bringing this
artifact back home with us we still know
very little about it we do know however
for a fact that this thing gives off
extremely dangerous hallucinations to
almost everybody which means that this
marker is more deadly than we think they
need to start treating this thing like a
psychotropic weapon with capabilities to
infect every living thing at close range
i mean look at it these guys have no
idea what they're getting themselves
into and based on their reactions are
unprepared as hell to handle this thing
and it'll cost them but there's one
thing even bigger than the marker
that'll have you wish you knew so much
more about and that is our sponsor for
today's video skillshare skillshare is
amazing i've been on there for a solid
few weeks and this is nothing like i had
growing up black seriously there's two
teachers that i really enjoyed learning
from and that is donald fitzgerald and
aaron lillis skillshare has so much to
offer for newbies and seasoned pros like
myself
there's something for everyone vo acting
classes audio editing writing marketing
and so much more so whatever it is
you're interested in learning more about
go to skillshare they can help you make
2022 a year of new learning growth
through connection and creativity so if
you want to be the next great anime
drawing artist vo guy video editing guy
whatever it is that you want to be go to
skillshare and level up your game invest
in yourself because the first 1000
people who use this link will get a one
month free trial of skillshare how
amazing is that and thank you skillshare
for sponsoring this video this
horrifying alien marker is then taken
back to the planet station where it is
held in waiting waiting for a ship known
as the ishimura to take this artifact
back home to earth but this is just the
beginning over the next month savage
violence begins taking place among crew
members on the planet station just as
the ishimura reaches the planet in time
for the markers extraction however some
station crew members like this guy think
this thing is cursed and that this very
artifact is the cause of all the murders
recently too bad everyone else thinks
this is all pure coincidence everyone
except that guy and this girl named
alyssa chief of the ship's security who
heads to the captain and informs him
that she doesn't think the marker should
remain on this ship for transport any
longer because ever since they brought
the marker onto the ishimura the same
upticks and crew violence that happened
on the planet station started happening
again on the ship the very same day they
brought that marker on board but the
captain thinks she's crazy and blames
all the murders and violence due to deep
space fatigue which is a cause from
being in space too long alyssa think
it's mad and wonders why this thing is
so important but the captain assures her
that once his scientist studies it then
she'll be able to do a full analysis
okay i have a question one why won't the
captain let the chief security officer
do a full analysis first before the
scientist safety first anyone but while
the captain may seem like he's taking
this too lightly he does have a point
about the crew having deep space fatigue
because the reality is space flight puts
an exorbitant amount of stress on the
body not to mention the high stress work
environment and consistent pressure to
perform without fault and that puts
space workers at all sorts of risks of
developing emotional stress with
astronauts for example having an average
of 3 to 58 chance of developing
post-traumatic stress disorder from
simply being in space compared to the 1
to 14 chance that the general public on
earth have of developing ptsd and with
this comes an 84 chance of alcoholism 42
chance of drug abuse 68 chance of
depression and 26 chance of anti-social
personality disorder and did i also
mention that the ishimura ship has been
in space for already two years that
means that the chances for on-orbit and
post-spaceflight psychiatric issues jump
up exponentially in short folks it's a
huge coincidence that all these deaths
began to occur as soon as that marker
was brought in but we can't deny that
people who have been in space for too
long have a way higher likelihood of
losing their minds and we gotta take
this into account first before blaming
it on outside forces right outside of
the ship the ishimura then gets ready to
crack this planet a process done to
deplete a planet's resources because of
this a massive gravity raid then beams
down onto the planet pulling an entire
segment of the planet's crust right off
and this monolith rock begins ascending
high into the sky and we get to see the
menacing nature of humanity's future
potential back on the ishimura these
doctors try to get to the bottom of why
passengers have suddenly started going
insane and this crazy guy then mentions
that he needed to kill because they need
bodies to turn but this doctor has no
idea what the hell he's talking about
and thinks he's crazy blaming his
hallucinations on the meds he's taking
then this doctor comes in and asks what
the hell is going on but the nurse says
that she's already gave him enough
sleeping meds to put down a horse around
500 cc's of anesthesia something is
keeping him awake and it's sure not the
medicine the doctor and the nurse
eventually managed to put him back to
sleep and he walks outside to find even
more lettuce fresh corpses surrounding
him he knows something is going on but
what this is insane think about it this
guy is way past any normal dose of
anesthesia around 5 000 milligrams which
is about a thousand times over the
average dose of anesthetic this means
that either this man weighs about 400
kilograms or something within his
central nervous system is simply
overpowering his state of being because
he should be out cold if not dead with
that much sleeping drugs in his system
as a doctor this would be outside of the
realm of medical science and i wouldn't
overlook the subtle signs that something
is seriously wrong with this guy and the
problem is this guy was fine and normal
a week ago and in that time has gone
from normal to full-on loco and
murderous now unless he experienced a
severe bout of emotional stress or
trauma head injury stroke tumors or
something i don't see how this man could
go insane in that short of a time span
as mental cases usually come about in
stages and over time also the fact that
multiple people just like him have
started to go insane all of a sudden out
of nowhere is beyond coincidence now i
get it we're in space you can go a
little nuts but how is it that people by
the dozen are all acting the same way
right now because we know for a fact
that the marker causes hallucinations
which means that these medically trained
professionals need to start looking at
the obvious signs that something is
about to go down on the ishimura and
maybe consider abandon ship the doctor
escorts another corpse into a room full
of dead bodies covered under crisp
blood-soaked white blankets filling yet
another room of victims victims of
what's soon to come just then a massive
rumble hits the ship causing concern
with everybody on it but the captain
assures them that it is normal
electromagnetic surges caused by this
planet's magnetic field bleeding out and
they continue to extract resources from
this chunk of rock arousing more fear
than curiosity among the concerned ship
crew who knows this time something
doesn't feel right but then all of a
sudden another massive rumbling this
time bigger than the last one erupts
across the entire ship violently shaking
everything and everyone causing the
captain to let out a little more fear in
his reassuring words than he'd like the
crew doesn't know what's going on and
thinks something is wrong with the ship
a temporary glitch perhaps the captain
then orders the ship to make contact
with the colony back on the planet but
the crew mentions that the signal is
choppy alyssa and bald guy here think
that something from somewhere is
intentionally cutting off their signal
but the crew laughs in her face the ship
finally makes contact with the planet
station and are told that the surface is
not doing much better with the entire
land violently shaking thinking all of
this to be the cause from the rock that
they extracted being too close to the
planet's core but this pilot back on the
planet doesn't have time because all of
a sudden he sees the captain's call on
the screen turn into a horrifying
monster he's losing his mind and he's
not the only one finally landing at the
station these two guys exit the vehicle
but just then they notice that something
sinister is going on the station is
empty filled with nothing but thick
slime webbing and wall hugging vines it
looks like nobody's been here in 50
years but that's impossible this guy
thinks that something is off and parts
ways with his doomed co-pilot walking
past the hallway when he suddenly hears
distant screams followed by a horrifying
bellowing roar coming from something
terrifying he begins to run for his life
passing more and more dead corpses until
he finally reaches his room but this
room is like all the rest covered in
absolute mess and blood this man
desperately calls for his wife but she's
nowhere to be found in the distance this
man hears some noise and his eyes widen
he sees his wife covered in blood and
carrying an energized weapon uttering
the same words as the prisoner back on
the ishimura they want her bodies
tearing at her own body she finally does
the nasty and half slices her head off
dead i guess the marriage was too much
for her to bear okay this guy may be a
good husband but he's a bad human it's
safe to say that 500 years in the future
when all of this takes place that we as
humans by then would be even more
familiar with the classic horror tropes
that are out and about from the eerie
empty rooms to faint screams and monster
roars from creatures that he doesn't see
not to mention the blood-stained room
and signs of the marker in his own house
this man should have known that
something not ordinary was about to
happen and should have been more
prepared than he was for what's to come
also our wife just cut her own head
almost off she is literally dead weight
i wouldn't stick around to mourn her
much and i would leave and get to the
space station as soon as possible now we
don't know for sure where exactly this
guy is but if nearby i would stop at the
control room barracks if it was close
enough first before grabbing weaponry
because let's be honest this guy knew
there was something evil down here the
moment he and us heard those terrifying
alien screams in the distance so if he
knows what's good for him he'll arm up
and get the hell out of there back on
the ship the doctor tells the captain
that his last analysis on the marker
revealed a large psychosomatic energy
field unlike any other he's ever seen
but the captain still thinks that the
energy field that's hitting the ship is
coming from the planet and not the
marker the captain has gone way past
denial and is now fast approaching
suicidal but just then the ship finally
gets in contact with the security
cameras placed on the station back at
the planet and everybody in the room
finally sees the horrors that are going
on down there dead bodies everywhere
blood painted on the walls and no one
alive in sight alyssa then demands that
they send a security team back to the
planet when all of a sudden the onboard
assistant reveals that she's getting
multiple flatlines of everybody on the
planet colony more people are dying and
the screen turns blood red they are
being slaughtered but by what meanwhile
back on the planet this dude with his
wife in his arms is running away from
his room running towards the same ship
that he entered in as he rests his wife
down and starts the ship's thrusters
something flies into the ship right in
the nick of time and now his ship is on
a course back to the ishimura the horror
show has just begun and everybody on
board finally finds out that something
back on the planet is attacking them and
this guy says that something is killing
all of his men saying that something is
down there with them until we hear a
horrifying roar and the calm is cut off
alyssa has had enough and so has the doc
and he alerts the captain that they need
to send in reinforcements asap but the
captain has been a bad boy and no one
can find out where they are thanks to
his illegal drilling operation on this
planet's surface and he demands the dock
to keep his mouth shut what's going on
here is nothing like what the religious
texts suggest and the doc begs the
captain to at least inform the
unitologist church about what's going on
but the captain apparently doesn't care
and is more worried about his crew who
most are either part of the religious
church or are sympathizers with the
unitologist cause he cannot afford a
mutiny on his ship and sets course to
abandon the planet colony and head
straight for earth he can't let anyone
from the planet colony back on this ship
because he knows what i'm pretty sure
all of you now know everybody on the
planet colony is about to die suddenly
they are alerted to an incoming ship
it's the guy and his wife and they're
headed straight for the ishimura alyssa
demands that they let the incoming ship
on board but the captain puts on his big
boy voice and orders the ship to go on
lockdown now okay if i was the captain i
would agree the unitologist religion has
spread far and wide among everybody and
we know just how dangerous some
religious fanatics are and how far
they're willing to go for a cause and
judging from the marker's prominence and
the fact that this entire mission is
funded by the unitologist church itself
we might get some pushback if we tell
our crew something they don't like and
based on the history of ship mutinies
over time the act of ship mutiny
particularly means the open rebellion
against the captain of this ship the
highest in command which means we would
be screwed if we don't play our cards
right and to top this off we have a ship
coming straight from the tainted planet
itself as stone cold as it is we should
probably do what the captain is saying
because if we don't this incoming ship
could be the start of a major outbreak
which is why we're better off locking
down the ship and preventing the likely
infectious disease that is on board that
ship from entering ours but if they do
enter our ship the ship should already
have in place measures to quarantine and
isolate incoming vessels from the jump
this is going to be able to help protect
the crew and everybody on board the ship
and help prevent exposure to whatever it
is that is out there including the
closure of all ventilation systems
present on the landing dock so even if
this ship makes it in they should not be
too big of concern if they set
everything up right back on the incoming
ship the guy pilots the hell out of his
cruiser refusing orders to stand down
just as his corpse of a wife comes back
from the dead and tears into his face
the captain forces all entrances on the
ship to close but the incoming ship just
manages to sneak through one open pod
bay door and the ship comes crashing
down onto the landing pad it's go time
alyssa and her security crew are ordered
to go down there and secure and
quarantine whatever the hell is on that
ship suiting up and bearing some space
glocks the security team approaches the
ship with caution but something is not
right with it as they slowly enter the
crashed ship they witness the horrors of
nothing the ship is empty except there
is blood everywhere whatever was on
board has slipped on through they come
across a hole at the front of a ship
with trail markings leading out of the
ship it's official something is now on
board the ishimura the team then moves
out hoping to find the source of all
this horror before it's too late back in
the quarantined lab the crazy prisoner
wakes up to a start terrified of what he
thinks he knows is going on and
something passes by him in the distance
he heads out barefoot past the doors and
right into a pile of blood blood leading
right into the morgue and this crazy
prisoner proves that he's stupid enough
to ignore the warning signs and heads
into the morgue he comes across piles
and piles of body parts and corpses
covered in bloody goo and that's when he
sees it in the distance the most
horrifying winged creature slicing into
the forehead of a corpse injecting it
with something that then turns this body
into the most terrifying thing this
crazy prisoner has ever seen a murderous
dna altered space necromorph and they
come straight for this guy's throat and
the space prisoner tailcoat the hell out
of there faster than the wind god
hanuman himself but these necromorphs
are too quick for their own good and
stab him right through the gut forcing
him to come face to face with this
competitor-eater-looking alien monster
ripping him to shreds okay if i was a
prisoner on the ship i would have been
way more cautious before exiting that
room i would have at least taken some
weaponry or sedatives with me in case
anybody tried to arrest me but also he
just saw for himself blood on the floor
and chose to head to the dumbest place
one could go in a scary situation like
this the morgue this takes place 500
years in the future hasn't anyone ever
heard of every horror trope ever it's
obvious we know by now that something is
going on and due to the ishimura's
insane ventilation system we stand no
chance against whatever these things are
due to the fact that they can reach us
in almost any part of the ship once
again thanks to the damn ventilation
systems i would say screw the morgue and
go to arguably the most protected parts
of the ship i would either head down
towards the mining deck the medical bay
or the bridge maybe not the medical if
the cases down there have begun to surge
because these are the parts of the ship
that will be the most heavily secured i
would also find some change of clothes
along the way to pass off as a harmless
passenger but in any case when it all
goes to hell and it will i doubt anyone
would care that my fake identity is not
on the passenger manifest in the main
control room this glasses guy lets the
captain know that it's official they've
lost all contact with the planet colony
and the dock thinks that the captain
needs to let someone on earth know just
what the hell is going on here but the
captain yet again refuses ordering the
duck to go down to check on the marker
in other areas of the ship a crowd is
gathering right in front of where the
proclaimed marker is causing security
around it to tighten they suspect that
something is going on and it's all
because of the one thing that they
believe in the marker itself the dog
arrives just as the workers get rowdy
but this unitologist believe in ponytail
guy here tells the doc that he can help
calm everyone down and he eases the
heightened tensions that everyone is
feeling and he sends the anchored crowds
away from the marker easing what
everybody knows on this ship knows yet
that they are all about to die the duck
while studying the marker suddenly looks
up and sees this horrifying corpse or
does he back at the mourn alyssa's team
reaches the gore-filled room finding
nothing yet again except the rummages of
monsters who were once there 20 corpses
suddenly gone and there's not a single
one in this room alyssa then calls this
into the captain just as this necromorph
wakes up right behind this guy throwing
him to the floor and gnawing at his
flesh alyssa gets the thing off of him
and the crew joins in to help flinging
the beast away from them but another one
pops up before the team blasts it into
oblivion the gang wonders just what the
hell is this just as the captain radios
in but another monster comes in and is
blasted in the face alyssa has had
enough and orders the team to secure the
room and move on nobody has any idea
what's going on except the ship's dock
who tells the captain all of this is
connected to the alien marker what are
they doing we know that this thing on
the ship is an infection of sorts and as
with any infection the goal is to spread
to convert more hosts and to spread the
infection even further and from what
we've seen it doesn't look like the
infection can't be spread through bites
or scratches it seems like the only way
to spread is through death that these
things can be reanimated into the
creatures that we now know but at this
point it's safe to say that the
infection is spreading faster than we
can contain it so our best bet would be
to monitor and defend all key parts of
the ship vital to the continuing
operation of managing the ishimura
depending on how many men we have in
total on our security team i would
station them at the engineering deck the
hydroponics deck which is necessary for
the sustained production of the ship's
oxygen i would also place men at the
medical deck the computer core where
we'll be able to control remotely
locking down and unlocking various areas
i would also play some guys at the tram
system the filtration system and the
captain's bridge doing this will be
easier than running wild on a goose
chase trying to catch whatever is
already on the loose the doctor is right
the marker's influence has taken over
the whole ship and is turning everybody
into horrifying necromorphs that hunt
down and turn dead humans into
alien-like creatures there's no stopping
these things now the captain and crew
see the horrors that plague the ship and
the captain sounds off the alarm sending
alyssa to the mess hall to put a final
stop to this but it's too late the mess
hall is littered with corpses and even
worse this army of feeding necromorphs
alyssa and her crew fire at the incoming
army who quickly overwhelm all of them
and knock down a few key members causing
them to fight these demons at close
range the necromorphs have knocked over
muscle sky knocking this guy over and
biting this blonde guy repeatedly alyssa
knows they're outmatched and she sees
muscle guy get decapitated right in
front of her with soul patch guy about
to get ripped to shreds till suddenly
ponytail guy comes in hot and saves them
all alyssa thanks ponytail guy for
saving their asses and the gang goes to
collect the very same weapon that this
unitologist lovin fanatic is rocking
alyssa contacts the pilot room where the
captain is but no response this blonde
guy then says that they need to get the
hell out of there but too bad alyssa has
two goodie two shoes to listen and says
that they need to save as many people as
they can on the ship first before
anything else happens honestly why
doesn't alyssa just think about the
reality of the situation we're a small
crew we do not know much about these
necromorphs we're not going to be able
to save many if at all how about we just
listen to blonde douchebag over here
because there's no way that we can stop
all of this i would ask ponytail guy
where he got his weapon from and suit up
because screw saving everyone here
alyssa and her crew need to start
thinking for themselves and i would
start by escorting them near the control
room and flight room specifically the
captain's nest because right near there
is the one thing that will guarantee
we'll live to fight another day and that
is dare i say the escape pods which are
right next to the captain's observation
area i say screw the ishimoto let's save
our crew and get out of there alyssa and
her crew then team up with ponytail guy
and the gang prepares to head back to
the pilot room at the pilot room the
staff alerts the captain that they've
lost communication with everybody on the
ship and this causes the captain to
sweat bullets he orders the team to lock
down all areas of the ship and plot a
course for earth immediately however the
dock finally has had enough and argues
with the captain that they both know
that the marker is a trap they need to
get rid of it but the captain demands
that the marker to be delivered to the
church if humanity is to have any chance
of being welcomed at the universal
awakening and that's when it finally
hits the captain has clearly lost his
mind and now the doc knows and so do all
the crew members the doc thinks the
marker is causing the captain to be
paranoid and delusional and the captain
demands that the dock be arrested but
the crew has had enough of the captain's
insane orders and try to arrest him
instead the dog tries to get in on the
psychotic fun and tries to stick the
captain with a sedative but misses and
stabs his eye killing the captain
whatever he's doing has cut every single
person on this ship off from the rest of
humanity and now everyone knows it and
just then the ship ejects every single
emergency pod that the ship has into
space forcing everyone to now be
stranded and at the mercy of the
ishimura's horrifying demise whatever is
doing all of this has cut every single
person on this ship off from the rest of
humanity and now everyone knows it all
emergency shuttles have now gone deep
into space back at alyssa's group the
gang comes across more horrifying
necromorphs that send the gang running
into the utility lift and through these
giant blast doors but something is wrong
with blonde hair guy and alyssa notices
blonde hair guy claims it's nothing as
they enter this expansive vegetation
room alyssa then asks bald guy to keep
an eye on blonde guy but he's too insane
to keep under control forcing blue hair
girl to knock him down but then he
begins muttering the same words that the
psycho prisoner from earlier said
claiming that they want our bodies just
then this giant necromorph pops out and
tries to attack blue hair girl and the
gang acts quickly slicing off all of its
limbs and its baby little monsters left
and right but there's too many of them
more and more necromorphs come charging
at everyone slicing limbs left and right
and blood spurts everywhere blonde guy
even manages to slice blue hair girl
hannibal style and charges at alyssa
blonde guy has officially lost his mind
before he gets shot in the head by bald
guy they know that it's official the
marker is making everyone lose their
minds either they will all be killed by
these necromorphs or they will kill each
other back at the bridge with the
captain dead and having lost control of
the ship the crew thinks hard of what to
do next there's no way to contact earth
and no escape off of the ship itself and
it's only a matter of time until the
monsters come in here to get them
suddenly they lose power and hear
hard-hitting rumbles at the front door
the doors finally open up but luckily
it's alyssa and her crew the crew tells
eliza that the captain is dead and that
they can't reach anyone on the com nor
can alyssa reach the rest of her squads
but just then a huge alarm sounds off
and the guidance computer holding the
ship up in orbit loses power the
ishimura is now slowly falling out of
orbit being pulled by the planet and if
they don't do anything soon they will
all come crashing down into the planet
itself the crew then finds out that the
person meddling with the ship's function
is none other than the dock himself
alyssa demands that they try and stop
him putting everyone else's safety above
hers and the crew heads out to find the
dock as they roam the corpse-filled
hallways eliza then hears panicked
screams and finds some people trapped in
a room waiting to be eaten and skinned
alive by these necromorphs ponytail guy
then sacks up and distracts the monsters
as alyssa sneaks in through the vent
shaft to help the trapped passengers
saving countless lives but losing
ponytail guy as he fights these
necromorphs to the death alyssa and her
final teammate baldguy reached the
computer room where the dock is as he
tries to bypass the locks causing the
attention of more horrifying necromorphs
to head their way but they don't have
enough time so like all his comrades
before him baldguy sacrifices himself to
save alyssa allowing her to catch the
dock red-handed and knocks him back
getting into a tussle between the two
the dog being the man of science says
that he thinks the infection is too
dangerous and that everyone on the ship
all needs to die to ultimately save
humanity from catching this plague but
alyssa being the badass babe that she is
refuses to give up and beats him the
hell up before stabilizing the ship but
the dock runs off and it's not over
because she's beginning to feel the
effects of the marker too and it's only
a matter of time before she turns into
one of them unable to reach anyone
alyssa then reaches the place where it
all began the marker itself just as she
sees an army of necromorphs coming for
her she runs with all of her might about
to die until the necromorphs stop
chasing her it seems as though the
marker is preventing them from getting
too close but she's not out of the woods
yet because alyssa passes out okay you
know what we might be in a good
situation right now because we found the
only spot on the entire ship where these
flesh-eating bastards can't get us so i
say let's take it slow and use whatever
we have to make the most of it everyone
is dead and the mission has failed
arguably in every possible way but we do
have one thing on our side and that is
the miraculous feats of the human body
itself the human body can survive for up
to two months without any food but only
up to four days without any water if
we're stuck here for the long haul i
would say wait it out until help comes
if ever it's a long shot i know i'd say
kick back for a few hours and let the
initial appeal of ourselves towards the
necromorphs wear off then as they
eventually scatter around the ship i
would make a run to scavenge for water
primarily and food if possible and that
wouldn't be our main concern we also
have a computer with us which we can use
for some sort of intel and or to monitor
procedures happening on the ship to a
degree so i say let's make this plot of
land right in front of our marker our
new base and slowly but surely begin
running around for supplies over the
next few days at this point this is
alyssa's best course of action waking up
cold feeble and aimless she then goes to
record her plight onto a nearby computer
flight log telling the world the truth
of what happened on the ishimura
believing that the marker is the cause
of all of this and that whoever finds
this message needs to destroy the marker
alyssa signs out and begins the sequence
to open the airlock doors just as she
runs for her sweet life onto the ship
right as the seal doors begin to open
and flood the room with the cold vacuum
emptiness of space ejecting every horror
from that room out including alyssa
herself floating on the brim of aegis
7's orbit slowly subcoming to the silent
screams of space suddenly an incoming
ship radios in on the ishimura hearing
nothing but silence on the coms and it
prepares to board the cursed vessel
reigniting a new sequence of horrifying
events that are about to unfold yet
again and if you don't like sexy ass
space monsters coming for your flesh
then like comment let us know what you
liked and of course didn't like and
don't forget to check out the how to be
playlist down below